fin de la conférence de paris sur les
armes chimiques la communauté
internationale s'est engagée à ne pas
les utiliser et à les détruire
la france demande à la syrie
l'extradition d'aloïs brüner c'est le
plus grand criminel de guerre nazi
vivant municipal suite deux exemples ce
soir deux villes qui ne font pas comme
les autres grenoble hébreu
un plan pour l'exportation qui reste le
point faible de l'économie française
dans ce journal
l'exemple des maisons de commerce
japonaise les campagnes anti tabac
certes elle a quelque chose aux états
unis près de la moitié des fumeurs ont
arrêté vous tenter d'arrêter de fumer
bonsoir et cette affaire bien
douloureuse pour commencer le journal
les deux jeunes fiancés de fontainebleau
ont sans doute été assassiné hier soir
nous vous disions dans ce même journal
que deux corps avaient été découverts en
forêt de fontainebleau ce matin on a eu
la triste confirmation il s'agissait
bien de ceux de gilles neau des haies et
d'anne sophie van damme ce soir
l'enquète apporte encore des éléments
nouveaux
isabelle stress à 300 mètres sur ce
plateau l'endroit où ont été découverts
les corps
trois cadavres en état de décomposition
dissimulés sous des bruits hier près
d'une mare depuis hier une centaine de
gendarmes fouillaient le secteur à la
recherche du moindre indice
dès ce matin le chien était identifié
grâce à son collier il s'agissait bien
de dundee le jeune berger de giniaux des
et anne sophie van damme autre indice
les vêtements ils seraient identiques à
ceux du jeune couple disparu il ya deux
mois ce soir il n'y a donc plus de doute
sur l'identité des deux victimes
mais elle sera confirmée officiellement
par l'autopsié pratiquée demain peu
vraisemblable d'envisager l'hypothèse
d'un accident fortuit d'une mort
naturelle
je ne sais quelle autre hypothèse autre
qu'une hypothèse criminelle c'est donc à
la recherche des auteurs d'un crime que
sinon exclusivement du moins
prioritairement les enquêteurs vont
désormais se tourner une information
judiciaire pour homicide volontaire a
été ouverte
les enquêteurs devront déterminer
notamment si les jeunes gens sont morts
sur place ou si plus vraisemblablement
leurs corps ont été déposés là par le ou
les meurtriers
la fin de la conférence de paris sur les
armes chimiques les cent quarante et
quelques pays qui participaient ont
finalement publié un texte qui est un
engagement solennel
ne pas utiliser les armes chimiques mais
aussi détruire celle qui existe en
revanche il n'y a pas dans le texte de
référence à l'arme nucléaire
la rédaction de ce texte et fait bien
sûr à l'arraché georges bortoli palais
de l'unesco
15h50 je déclare que l'acte final est
adoptée par consensus adopté à
l'unanimité la déclaration finale de la
conférence de paris condamne comme on
l'espérait larmes schyle
certes il y a eu jusque au bout des
réserves de la part de certains
regrettant par exemple qu'on parle trop
de larmes chimiques et pas assez de
l'arme atomique mais finalement tout le
monde a été d'accord
alors dans ce texte de deux pages que
vient d'adopter la conférence qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'essentiel
il ya d'abord l'idée que la conférence
sur le désarmement qui siège à genève et
et cliq aux 40 nations va accélérer ses
travaux pour conclure aussi tôt que
possible une convention interdisant
complètement interdit jantes
définitivement larmes chimique le plus
tôt possible ça veut dire qu'en
évidemment on n'en sait rien précisément
mais beaucoup de gens dans la tête
l'année prochaine l'année 1990 nous
verrons bien
d'autre part tout de suite les états
participants s'engagent solennellement à
ne pas utiliser ou à ne plus utiliser
l'armé chimique alors vous me direz un
engagement ça vaut ce que ça vaut oui
mais tout de même quand un engagement
est pris devant une conférence de 149
pays
il est un petit peu plus solide dans la
mesure où to be a une image de marque à
son père d illizi donc à violer trop
ouvertement un engagement de cette
nature par conséquent on peut espérer
que dans les mois qui viennent
on ne verra pas on ne verra plus les
images horribles qui ont accompagné la
répression contre les kurdes et la
guerre de l'irak contre l'iran
la france demande à la syrie
l'extradition d'aloïs bruner bruner
c'est le plus grand criminel de guerre
nazi vivent une demande identique avait
été faite il y a cinq ans par
l'allemagne
les autorités syriennes ont toujours
répondu qu'elle ne connaissait pas
bruner isabelle des fleurs aloïs brunner
ancien bras droit ayman a aujourd'hui 76
vit depuis 30 ans en syrie à drancy
entre 43 et 44 mais aussi partout en
europe pendant toute la guerre il a fait
des portées plus de cent mille juifs
vers la mort des camps de concentration
comme barbie il a fait déportés des
convois entiers d'enfants juifs
j'ai toujours dit que barbie était un
chef de la gestapo de gestapo régionale
particulièrement cruelle et fanatiques
qui en a fait beaucoup plus mais bruner
ce n'est pas à l'échelle d'une région
c'est à l'échelle de l'europe entière
qu'il a sévi et il a déporté tous les
juifs d'autriche les juifs de la
macédoine grecque c'est-à-dire plus de
45 mille juifs et a pas en france il a
été un des dirigeants de la solution
finale
voilà sept ans que m klarsfeld a
localisé brunner à damas où il avait
créé structures et les services secrets
syriens
son enquête a permis à la france
d'adresser à la syrie une demande
d'extradition motiver les syriens ont
sans doute fait mieux pour l'instant de
ne pas connaître aloïs brunner
mais comme pour klaus barbie m klarsfeld
est tenace et confiant et aujourd'hui je
peux vous annoncer la demande
d'extradition française c'est parce que
la france a la volonté de trouver une
solution et qu'elle y mettra le poids
nécessaire le poids nécessaire sera en
l'occurrence celui du ministre des
affaires étrangères roland dumas qui
perdit son père pendant l'occupation
allemande et plaida dans le procès
barbie pour les victimes de cet autre
bourreau l'économie ch avec une
constatation la conjoncture française
est bonne à un gros détail près le
commerce extérieur largement déficitaire
d'où ce matin au conseil des ministres
trois mesures pour améliorer les
exportations françaises
alors ces mesures je vous les donne un
rendre plus performant les services de
l'état qui est à l'exportation de former
les vendeurs notamment aux langues
étrangères et aux techniques d'export
justement
et puis trois la signature d'une charte
nationale avec tous les intéressés
alors voilà de belles 1,22 bel20 tension
pardon qui se heurteront peut-être une
nouvelle fois à la tradition des
entreprises françaises qui sont peut
porter ses vraies perles exportations
alors regardons comment font les autres
ceux qui réussissent les japonais bien
sûr et leurs maisons de commerce
christophe martet reportage ici ils ont
l'oeil sur tout nous sommes au siège
parisien de sitôt la plus
sogo shosha ou maison de commerce
japonaise créée il ya 130 ans elle
emploie dix mille collaborateurs dans
146 bureaux à travers le monde
c'est la force de frappe des entreprises
ni pas vu ce 1000e ou japonais mais
aussi cette organisation unique au monde
inspiré le plan gouvernemental de
soutien aux exportations
fini les efforts en ordre dispersé
désormais le centre français du commerce
extérieur et les chambres de commerce
devront travailler main dans la main
à l'image des réseaux japonais le plan
prévoit aussi un coup de pouce à la
formation les futurs exportateurs
apprendre les langues dès l'école
primaire et à l'université on va créer
de nouvelles filières spécialisées
mais cet appui logistique ne remplacera
pas la volonté des entreprises apparaît
tout aussi nécessaire sinon davantage
que les entreprises aient les moyens
d'utiliser ses services et ses appuis et
elles en sont très loin il faut savoir
par exemple que les deux tiers des 33
mille entreprises exportatrices n'ont
pas même une personne à plein temps pour
s'occuper des ventes sur leurs marchés
extérieurs une lacune qui profite déjà
au maison de commerce japonaise
ainsi c'est ito paris réalise le quart
de son activité en vendant son
savoir-faire aux entreprises françaises
exportatrices dernier contrat en date
l'entreprise de matériel de travaux
publics potins qui a signé dans ce
bureau un contrat de 16 millions de
francs avec le japon oui je doute que
demain jean marie rausch le ministre du
commerce extérieur sera l'invité des 4
vérités présenté par gérard morin dans
télématin et puis je profite de
l'occasion pour vous présenter le bilan
économique 88 publié par le monde
toujours un remarquable document qui
s'interroge cette fois cette année pour
savoir si l'embellie actuelle de
l'économie occidentale va durer les
municipales demain une rencontre pierre
mauroy et georges marchais les deux
leaders du ps et du pc la gauche devrait
enfin y trouver un accord ce soir nous
vous proposons un regard sur deux villes
atypique d'abord grenoble dont je vous
parlais hier la le maire rpr alain
carignon a réussi à tirer sur sa liste
des socialistes
enquête claude régent
nevache a de solides références
socialiste il a été le suppléant de
pierre mendès-france et celui d'hubert
dubedout maire socialiste de grenoble
pendant 18 ans aujourd'hui guy nevache
passe une alliance avec précisément le
tourer surprise d'hubert dubedout en 83
alain carignon est un homme maire de
grenoble qui n'a pas tourné le dos aux
réalisations de son prédécesseur hubert
dubedout qui j'étais très attaché et
dont j'étais très proche
il les a au contraire souvent poursuivis
et développé après le ralliement à ses
côtés d'haroun tazieff le volcanologue
de gauche alain carignon a réussi un
nouveau coup tout en se défendant
d'arrière pensées politiciennes crois
que le problème pour gérer une ville
c'est de rassembler toutes les
compétences et toutes les énergies et
que cela ne se résume pas un parti
politique ou à des alliances de partis
politiques les socialistes grenoblois
dont la liste sera conduite par leurs
gardiens michel destot se rassurent
pour eux la défection de guinée vache
n'est qu'un acte individuel isoler la
grille politique est souvent émaillées
de personnalités qui décide de changer
de camp dit nevache a fait ce choix
eh bien il n'a plus rien à voir avec le
parti socialiste et le combat des
socialistes sur grenoble dans une ville
largement mitterrandiste le ps n'a pas
perdu tout espoir de reconquête
alain carignon doit donc trouver
l'ouverture à gauche ses convictions
personnelles rejoignent une nécessité
politique autre ville atypique dreux
elle l'a toujours été en raison du
nombre important d'immigrés par exemple
et aussi bien sûr de l'importance du
front national est bien à dreux le rpr
ne s'alliera pas avec le front national
enquête en rien ni la cohabitation entre
le front national et l'opposition rpr
udf par est ici bien compromise
le maire gaulliste jean lié au candidat
à sa propre succession entend donc bien
conserver son siège sans l'appui du
front et par une campagne pugnace je
n'accepte pas je n'ai jamais accepté
d'agir sous la pression d'un parti
politique quel qu'il soit à partir de
rendre le front national depuis des mois
indique qu'en france et en particulier
entre
c'est une liste à part pour pouvoir
peser sur l'action du maire en l'espèce
de moi je n'accepte pas d'agir sous la
pression pour lui la liez de l'air
devient effectivement l'adversaire du
scrutin de mars prochain
un point sur lequel insiste d'ailleurs
marie france stirbois dont l'époux était
depuis 83
le premier adjoint front national de
jean miot ajoutant même qu'aujourd'hui
le maire a sans aucun doute la mémoire
bien que souvenir qu'en 83 nous avions
fait l'alliance
il donne une image là d'un maire qui
rejoint un petit peu monsieur mitterrand
dans ses déclarations 31 descente c'est
à dire qu'il exclut une partie la
population de wez comme monsieur
mitterrand ex une partie les français en
s'adressant surtout aux immigrés moi je
suis un petit peu désolé mais j'ai
l'impression la façon dont le chili au
procès qu'il va réintroduire le loup
socialiste dans la galerie municipale et
ça c'est très dangereux et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ne se rend pas très
bien qu'on des paroles qui a prononcé
après ce divorce quasi officielle entre
le front national et le maire apparenté
rpr on vient d'apprendre également
qu'une poignée de centristes s'affichait
déjà sur une liste des dissidents
socialistes dreux devenu un véritable
petit marseille a de quoi inquiéter le
maire pour son siège et pour être tout à
fait complet sur ce dossier des
municipales et bien sachez que pierre
méhaignerie souhaite que l'udf réexamine
le cas de lille il a demandé à valéry
giscard d'estaing
il souhaite que l'udf défendent bruno
durieux qui se présente sur une liste
séparée lui même
monsieur méhaignerie soutiendra bruno
durieux l'enseignement c'est sans doute
le grand dossier politique actuellement
dans ce domaine michel rocard prend le
taureau par les cornes pour rénover
l'enseignement
le premier ministre en a fait une
priorité exemple en 89 6 milliards de
francs supplémentaires seront débloqués
pour quoi faire
explications chantal kimmerlin cette
fois c'est sérieux l'éducation est bien
la priorité des priorités
les 4 milliards d'augmentation annuel
promis par le président de la république
s'enrichissent de 2 milliards décroché
au gouvernement par lionel jospin
ces deux milliards principalement
consacrée à la revalorisation des
salaires des enseignants devraient
donner une marge de manoeuvre plus large
au ministre de l'éducation dans les
négociations avec les syndicats
le gouvernement propose en outre deux
types d'indemnités dont bénéficieront
les
saignant qui acceptent des tâches
complémentaires comme la d'individuels
aux devoirs ou qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles de certaines zones
prioritaires l'enveloppent budgétaire
prend en compte également la rénovation
plus générale du système scolaire et la
création de trois nouveaux corps
d'enseignants les instituteurs les
professeurs de collèges et les
professeurs de lycée une finesse du
gouvernement pour recruter de nouveaux
enseignants sur une nouvelle grille de
salaires et de nouvelle redéfinition du
temps de travail
l'augmentation des crédits pour
l'éducation est le résultat d'une longue
concertation gouvernementale
reste à savoir si les moyens seront
jugés suffisants par les syndicats les
campagnes antitabac certes elle a
quelque chose
la réponse pour les états unis en tout
cas fait oui depuis qu'il y à 25 ans un
rapport de la santé publique américaine
avait lié le cancer du poumon à la
consommation du tabac depuis les
campagnes n'ont pas cessé aux états unis
et elles ont été efficaces nous allons y
revenir
il faut dire que les documents présentés
sur les chaînes de télévision
américaines sont parfois d'une vérité
est d'une cruauté totale
regardez celui ci où les cowboys aussi
sont victimes du tabac pendant dix ans
john holmes 64 ans je sentis patraque
maintenant je suis fichu
kazem de sebha il est atteint
d'emphysème
je crois que sa femme pour l'attend à
son rang
c'est dur à décrire la douleur est
permanente
j'ai besoin d'oxygène pour respirer j'ai
fumé pendant trente ans c'est long mais
j'ai fumé un pauvre petit homme
maintenant non ceux qui n'ont pas de
force pas d'espoir qu'ils s'en fichent
je crois est mort du cancer du poumon
résultats de ces campagnes en tout cas
en 65 40 % des américains adultes fumée
et bien maintenant ils ne sont plus que
29 % des résultats que les français
devraient sûrement méditer en france en
effet les campagnes anti tabac n'ont
jamais vraiment marché
quant aux lois anti tabac elles ne sont
bien souvent pas respectée
enquête alain labouze aujourd'hui à 14h
sur les champs elysées avant roger
rabbit première séance la pub sur l'
aventure de l'évasion
du rêve pour les vrais héros des temps
modernes sur huit spots publicitaires
quatre concernait des marques de
cigarettes par le biais faussement
déguisée des allumettes ou des briques
et publicité totalement interdite
aujourd'hui
difficile donc de faire appliquer la loi
difficile aussi d'arrêter de fumer moi
je fume pas ce que je pense trop parce
que j'ai envie est un grand acteur au
monde savait pas marché du tout j'ai
tenu trois mois je crois qu'on part et
on dépense en france un milliard de
francs par an pour la publicité des
produits n'étaient pas là noah n'est
donc pas appliquée pourquoi parce qu'il
ya des blocages au niveau de certains
secteurs qu'il faut explorer il faut
lever ces blocages pour entrer enfin
dans l'action concrète
il faut enfin que ce secteur soit
défendue sous l'angle de la santé et non
plus sous l'angle de l'économie prenez
l'exemple actuel du paris dakar
c'est une promotion de certaines marques
de cigarettes il faut qu'en 1990 le
paris dakar et yeux s'en vanter les
mérites de la cigarette
claude evin le ministre de la santé a
décidé de renverser la vapeur
il a demandé aux professeurs hirsch pour
la fin du mois de mars
un train de mesures vraiment concrètes
et incitative il faudra par exemple
expliqué que l'hôpital n'est pas le
meilleur endroit pour fumer et tout
faire pour que le chiffre de 93
milliards de cigarettes vendues chaque
année puissent enfin baisser contrôle
anti sida en union soviétique pour les
étrangers tous les résidents étrangers
en urs ceux qui restent plus trois mois
tous ceux là devront soit subir un test
soit présenté un certificat de leur pays
je vous propose maintenant de voir
d'autres informations importantes dans
l'actualité internationale de ce
mercredi michel mompontet l'équipage du
boeing 737 qui s'est écrasé le 10
janvier dernier en angleterre aurait
fait une fausse manoeuvre
juste avant le crash c'est ce que révèle
l'analyse
noir trouvé sur les lieux de l'accident
alors que le réacteur gauche de
l'appareil était en feu
un des deux pilotes auraient coupé les
gaz mais du réacteur droit
cette erreur de manipulation
s'expliquerait selon les spécialistes
par l'affolement dans le cockpit
à moins que les signaux de contrôle des
fonctionner mais à l'envers
la première mine manifestants dans les
rues de titograd ont obtenu aujourd'hui
ce qu'ils réclamaient depuis soit jours
la démission collective du gouvernement
de cette république du sud de la vive
hausse la vie le monténégro une
république environ quatre fois plus
pauvre que le reste du pays
25 % de chômage est déclaré
officiellement par le parti communiste
monténégrins comme je cite en faillite
je n'exclus pas la possibilité que des
entreprises allemandes aient pu
participer à la construction de l'usiné
libyenne de raptor c'est ce qu'a déclaré
lors de sa traditionnelle conférence de
presse de début d'année
le chancelier helmut kohl tout en
reconnaissant n'avoir actuellement pas
de preuves suffisantes contre les firmes
allemandes incriminé le chancelier kohl
a déclaré que six épreuves lui parvenait
il considérerait ces agissements
allemand en libye comme un véritable
crime
edf a de nouveau des problèmes avec ses
centrales nucléaires là il s'agit du
stockage du combustible
une partie des alvéoles de stockage
s'est déformée tout un matériel qui
devient ainsi inutilisable comme quoi
dans ce domaine du nucléaire il est bien
difficile de tout prévoir
patrice pollet
c'est ici il ya six mois dans cette
piscine de stockage de la centrale
nucléaire de nogent-sur-seine que
l'incident est arrivé
une de ces barres d'uranium qui sert de
combustible est resté coincé au fond de
l'eau dans une de ces 630 alvéoles
branle bas de combat des ingénieurs qui
après plusieurs essais parviendront
enfin à extraire cette barre
c'est sans doute une réaction chimique
entre l'aluminium et l'eau qui est à
l'origine de la déformation des parois
des alvéoles
avec 12% au moins 20 % elles veulent
déformer ça ne compromet pas
l'utilisation des ces piscines à
l'extrême limite si on avait trop
d'alcool condamné bien on serait obligé
de retirer ses intérieurs pour mettre en
place de nouvelles alvéoles avec une
technique sony pour fait différente
charger et décharger le coeur d'un
réacteur est une nécessité absolue
trop d'alves et elle en mauvais état et
c'est une centrale que l'on sort est
obligé d'arrêter
pour le moment on n'en est pas là
l'incident et déclarés mineurs et la
sécurité est assurée puisque la piscine
de stockage et leurs acteurs sont
totalement indépendants
plusieurs centrales sont potentiellement
menacés par le même mal à mal sur lequel
les ingénieurs se penchent depuis six
mois pour trouver la parade le procès
des terroristes d'action directe les
quatre leaders sont jugés en ce moment
vous savez pour le meurtre de george
besse le patron de la régie renault
mais cet après midi il n'était pas dans
le prétoire ils ont refusé d'assister à
l'audience de ce fait l'audition des
témoins prévus ce mercredi a été
beaucoup plus rapide
dominique verdeilhan un box
désespérément vide
un banc des avocats de la défense
partiellement déserté ils ont une bonne
partie de l'après midi rejoint leurs
clients dans la salle d'attenté des
accusés incarcérés dans des maisons
d'arrêt différentes
le quatuor a pu donc converser à loisir
dans les coulisses de leur procès comme
ils le réclamaient depuis lundi ce
procès est un procès politique leur
responsabilité est une responsabilité
politique non individuelle
de ce fait les frais maintenant on blanc
bien peu d'importance et nos clients ont
dit dans leurs déclarations ce qu'ils
avaient à dire à la barre témoignage
émouvant du chauffeur de georges besse
qui reconnaît les lambeaux de la
serviette de son patron un patron à qui
ils avaient révèle-t-il demandé de
prendre des précautions
depuis qu'il avait aperçu une femme aux
aguets devant le domicile parisien du
couple témoignages accablants de l'homme
qui a vu une femme tirée elle n'a rien
dit elle avait un air professionnels
dépourvu d'émotion de quelqu'un qui
accomplit c'est une tâche qu'elle
s'était fixé un homme qui s'interroge
encore aujourd'hui pourquoi cette fan
elle pas éliminer le témoin dangereux
que j'étais puisque j'ai par la suite
identifié nathalie ménigon une question
restée sans réponse
la confrontation n'a pas eu lieu les
quatre accusés ont préféré pour
l'instant bout d un procès qu'ils
rejettent
à propos d'une autre affaire la voiture
du juge bernard at-elle été sabotés
c'est une hypothèse mais ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse le jce bernard c'est lui qui
avait en charge jusqu'au week-end
dernier le difficile dossier de la faire
quand son à son arrivée à lille où il
vient d'être promu il a failli avoir un
accident avec sa voiture suspect caniche
c'est au goût de la descente de la rampe
d'accès du parking que le juge bernard
s'aperçoit qu'il n'a plus de freins il
réussit pourtant à maîtriser sa voiture
avec le frein à main avant de
s'apercevoir que son moteur est en feu
incendie rapidement maîtrisé par le
concierge qui arrive avec un extincteur
l'audi gt était resté auparavant pendant
plus de deux heures sans surveillance
dans une rue derrière le palais de
justice
cent dix mille kilomètres l'état du
véhicule n'est pas impeccable mais il
avait été entièrement révisée vendredi
dernier les experts se sont longuement
penchés sur l'audi cet après midi
certains disent qu'ils auraient constaté
que le capot avant avait été forcée et
une durite d'essence sectionnés en tout
cas ce soir la thèse du sabotage ne
semble pas écartée par les enquêteurs
si évidemment si l'hypothèse
de l'origine criminelle est vérifiée
mais entendu c'est inquiétant tant pour
moi si vous voulez que pour les membres
de ma famille qui sont ailleurs
est-ce que depuis l'incident de
nouvelles mesures de protection ont été
prises à votre votre égard je sais pas
encore
vous le souhaitez peut-être oui qui
pourrait en vouloir au juge bernard pas
seulement des protagonistes de la
délicate affaire quand sont à toulon
dans son cabinet jean pierre bernard a
laissé quelques 250 dossiers plus ou
moins brûlant voilà et après tout c'est
dure réalité dont nous vous parlons
depuis 20 heures il ya un peu de rêve
c'est ce que propose le grand palais
pendant tout un trimestre avec une
exposition gauguin qui fera date par son
ampleur et par la qualité des oeuvres
qui sont exposés on peut même parier que
cette exposition sera de la même
envergure que l'exposition picasso en 67
d'autant qu'on a souvent un peu réduit
l'offre de google à ses toiles
tahitienne au grand palais on va
découvrir à partir de samedi que c'était
un peintre immense l'un des tout
premiers du siècle en avant-première
george v go nous fait visiter cette
exposition il n'a pas oublié que gauguin
comme brel son or à marquise les femmes
sont lascive au soleil redouté et s'il
n'ya pas d'hiver cela n'est pas tout le
monde connait gauguin ou croit le
connaître
innombrables sont les reproductions de
ses paysages polynésiens qui étanche
notre soif de paradis mais aussi bonne
soit elle
en s'approchant des originaux on
s'aperçoit qu'on le connaissait mal
il est méconnu à mon avis parce que pour
gauguin on pense à propos de gauguin on
pense surtout à ce héros maudit à ce
grand voyageur à se découvrir cet
illustrateur de l'éden des marquises
bon disons un peu le côté club med je
trouve qu'ils nient au peintre parce que
ça n'est pas ça bien sûr c'est ça c'est
merveilleux d'avoir pu savoir rendre la
beauté de ces endroits idylliques gd
nique
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant dans mon gars c'est que
c'est un admirable artistes mais ça on
oublie un peu
le mérite de cette rétrospective unique
et d'avoir rassemblé depuis la période
bretonne toutes les oeuvres
significatives de l'évolution de ce
peintre révolutionnaire et de découvrir
les influences qu'il a subie dans ce
café d'arles où régnaient madame jean où
il buvait de l'absinthe avec van gogh
on sait ce qu'il advint de leur amitié
orageuse comme un ciel de camard
regardez bien ces toiles elles n'ont
jamais été exposées à paris la plupart
viennent du rss jusqu'au 24 avril parmi
le million de visiteurs
beaucoup fredonneront avec celui qui
dort près de gauguin le temps
s'immobilise ont marqué une page cinéma
maintenant le nouveau coppola s'appelle
thacker c'est l'histoire vraie d'un
constructeur automobile américain qui a
fait sensation juste après la guerre
avec un modèle superbe qui avait 10 en
avance sur toutes les autres voitures
mais preston tucker a dû renoncer il a
dû baisser pavillon face aux grands
trusts automobile histoire du pot de
terre contre le pot de fer qui est aussi
l'histoire de coppola
face aux grandes compagnies d'hollywood
résultat un très grand film
michel coq michel pascal nous le
présente en 6 ford coppola revient après
les années difficiles et les films de
commande
il a choisi pour son premier sujet
personnel de nous raconter l'histoire
vraie de preston tucker
cet inventeur un peu fou qui a fait
trembler les grands trusts automobile
après la guerre en imaginant un
prototype révolutionnaire
avec l'aide du milliardaire aux radios
il mettra la clé sous la porte après un
procès retentissant qui brisent net le
rêve du chercheur
de là à voir dans quelques heures la
propre histoire de coppola il n'y a
qu'un pas que tout le monde s'empresse
de franchir puisque le réalisateur
confirme que c'est bien une parabole
lui un tas de succès et un tas d'échec
d'ennui et de revers tout le monde le
sait je suis persuadé que quand je serai
vieux monsieur de 90 ans
on essaiera de faire monter sur une
scène pour me donner des oscars et des
médailles mais je peux vous dire déjà
que je refuserais après la sortie de
tucker coppola ira présider au mois de
mai le jury du festival de cannes avant
déterminer un film sur new york
réalisé avec martin scorsese woody allen
enfin un grand frisson pour terminer
cette édition dans le cosmos il y à une
veuve noire comme cette araignées
voraces qui dévore son compagnon mêlant
cosmos cela donne un trou noir il y est
en effet là bas une étoile morte qui est
en train de dévorer sa voisine cela se
passe au centre de notre galaxie et
surtout cela confirme ce que penser de
nombreux astronomes le centre de notre
galaxie est bien un immense trou noir
bien sûr on ne peut rien y voir mais on
peut entendre
alors écoutons ensemble avec philippe
dumez les bruits qui nous viennent de
l'espace nous apprennent qu'il se passe
dans le cosmos des phénomènes monstrueux
ces notes de musique que vous entendez
sont émises par des pulsars des étoiles
en train de mourir des étoiles qui se
transforme en trou noir c'est à dire que
toute la matière se condense sur
elle-même dans un volume minuscules ou
même les particules de lumière sont
emprisonnés heureusement ces pulsars
émettent des sons que les astronomes et
coup de grâce à des normes antennes et
avec ce bruit très particulier ils
peuvent même reconstitué des images
c'est ainsi qu'ils ont pu s'apercevoir
qu'un pulsar était en train de dévorer
une étoile voisine cela se passe au
centre de notre galaxie et ce festin
cosmique est en train de grossir un trou
noir déjà géant dont la densité est un
million de fois supérieure à notre
soleil
cette tragédie spatial n'est pas sans
rappeler ce qui se passe sur terre avec
l'araignée la veuve noire qui dévore son
compagnon après une étreinte nuptiale
mais c'est la première fois que les
astronomes découvre des pulsars vorace
ou amoureux et il se pourrait bien qu'il
y en ait beaucoup d'autres dans
l'univers wii paraît même que ça
pourrait arriver pour notre propre
système
mais rassurez-vous pas avant dix
milliards d'années mari philippe dumaine
voilà il ya encore des points un tiercé
quarté + alors je vous donne les
pronostics de pierrette brès et demain
c'est sur l'hippodrome de cagnes sur mer
les voici 18 17 7 10 14 15 trêve et
quatre dans un instant la météo ce sera
laurent cabrol vous verrez c'est une
météo assez douces toujours dernier
journal 23h15 avec henri sannier à
demain soir